bundesanwalt dieter firma hatte am
mittwoch nach der verhandlung gesagt
dass die erneute einlassungen von stefan
ernst wohl mehr fragen aufgeworfen als
beantwortet hätte diesen muss er sich
jetzt zeit heute morgen kurz nach 10 uhr
stellen und dabei kristallisiert sich
immer mehr heraus dass der mord an
walter lübcke keineswegs ein versehen
oder sogar eine kurzschlussreaktion
gewesen sein kann sondern dass das
tatsächlich eine geplante tat ist die
wohl auch schon seit mai im gespräch
gewesen ist also das ist durchaus einen
plan gab den kasseler
regierungspräsidenten umzubringen
dazu gab mir wurde es jetzt kurz vor
mittag sehr spannend es kam sogar zu
einer unterbrechung die von stefan ernst
anwalt beantragt wurde
weil es um einen vermeintlichen
mitwisser und zwar soll davon ernst mit
einer dritten person über lücke
kommuniziert haben über den
verschlüsselten messenger-dienst trainer
ja da kam es jetzt zu der unterbrechung
damit die beiden sich besprechen können
und es wird sich jetzt im laufe des
tages dann herausstellen ob stefan ernst
eventuell sogar noch eine dritte person
belastet und zwar als mitwisser dass die
tat so lange wahrscheinlich jetzt
geplant worden ist kann nicht einfach
sein vor allem für die familie von
walter lübke wie verfolgt diese dem
prozess sie immer dabei ja die familie
die ist auch heute wieder im saal dies
vor allem auch weil sie auch fragen
stellen darf an stefan ernst und stefan
ernst selbst hatte der familie auch
angeboten ihre fragen zu beantworten
dazu können wir sicherlich heute abend
auch mehr sagen was von der familie
gefragt wurde und was stefan ernst dann
da geantwortet hat